um so la was it last year you did the
Ice protest show
oh no that was a few years back man was
that did you end up going because I know
you did something downtown L.A but did
you end up going to like the Border you
were doing like a show outside of the
Border in San Diego right yeah yeah and
I went to Mexico uh by the so but I went
to uh yeah I went to TJ and I went to an
actual like ice Detention Facility and
performed outside of it on a truck I was
gonna say it was on a truck right yeah
yeah I remember seeing that and I I DJ
in San Diego all the time and I go get
all my medicine from Tijuana so I know
how crazy that border especially because
what year was this was this 2020 19
Maybe
yeah that border during the Trump years
was [__] crazy nuts it was crazy
there was so many people yeah like nuts
and I think when we went over there to
get in like one of the um
what was the big like immigrant like uh
there like there's a lot of people
trying to seek asylum in the U.S and
they were stopped at in Tijuana into the
a lot of African people that was African
that I didn't and they were canceled I
went there yeah I mean just the way that
they were running that situation was
just like super inhumane and I was
really surprised to see so many African
people like West African people I think
they were from like Cameroon or Congo
there was some french-speaking Africans
and it was like you know hundreds upon
hundreds of people and the way that they
would
get contacted was like they get to the
front of this line of thousands of
people right and then they give them a
number on a piece of paper and then they
call that number sometime within the
next month like weeks on weeks and you
literally have to be within earshot to
hear your number called
to at the border at the border so you
kind of have to just hang out there for
months like to proceed so we're gonna
sleep on the sidewalk exactly what they
were doing it was like
it was gross definitely see the way that
they were treating human beings like I
was I was really taken aback by that but
that's also in the midst of like all the
things happening with the kids in the
detention facilities yeah I just
remember schools the cages the ages
blankets that were like like metallic
metallic aluminum foil aluminum foil
blankets and I think a lot of that
stuff's still going on right now it's
definitely still going on yeah because I
mean I you know I I was I'm definitely a
[__] Donald Trump type of guy but I
think a lot of that [__] was going on
before him too
I'm not making any excuses for him in
particular but you know what I'm saying
the uh hypocrisy of like American
oppression doesn't begin or end with
Donald Trump Donald Trump is just the
one that put it on Front Street he said
it's actually what I'm all I'm paying
all my [__] I'm here for the bag
straight like that [__] y'all this is
what presidents have been doing but he
just told your job just said what he was
on you know he just let y'all know what
was going down you said what he was on
that's why you know it's crazy too
because like I've like been like a
lifelong like you know liberal Democrat
guy like you know I voted for Joe Biden
but
this last [__] few years I just been
like
I just don't know where we go from here
like I don't know like how do you feel
about this next presidential election
because it really feels like somehow
we're gonna end up with the same two
guys and I don't know if either of them
are great for our country
and I just don't you know neither of
them are grateful no they're
definitively terrible Joe Biden has been
a terrible president and I voted for him
he just hasn't been great um but the guy
before him was terrible for his own you
know terrible for the racial division
the normalization of a lot of things
like him getting locked up and having
that hard ass mug shot too I think that
only helps his case bro I'm like it's
gonna be a Griselda album cover revenge
like West Side gun's next album cover
might be the Donald Trump
unfortunately that's only helping his
case that's what I'm telling I'm like yo
these guys if they're gonna go all in
they better make sure gotta slam him
because if he don't go to jail he's
gonna be the next president he can't
even run he can run from jail and he
will but I think he'll lose the primary
because I think there's enough I think
you'll lose but uh you'll be there's I
can't call it yeah you never know I
can't call it I mean like
Joe Biden too
I'm not gonna forget that Joe Biden is
responsible for the 1994 crime yeah yeah
the crime bill called people frustrated
and the system of mass incarceration as
we know it is millions he also nipped
the HBCU build it uh was supposed to
fund a lot of the hbcus that
was I think I think Trump put that
through
yeah Biden is listen man that's why I'm
like I don't know where what do we do do
we I'm like I told everybody I was just
talking to my uh my wife's uh mom and I
said if it's Trump versus Biden or if
it's like the Santos versus Biden I'm
just going to vote Cornell West and
[__] sleep well yeah it was no
Cornell I don't know
um what according to know Wes and Kanye
West ran on a double bill
um yo shout out to Kanye who was
definitely just getting blown in the
middle of a boat in Italy that's what
that's what that was what we thought it
was right okay okay
I didn't see that part I didn't see that
part
um
yeah this next this next selection I
can't call it man I don't know if I
would vote for Biden again I mean
honestly I think that it's always a
lesser of two evils situation but
sometimes it's hard to really determine
what the less of the two evils are a lot
of the guys
the guys want Trump because he gave him
PPP loans but the EDD was going crazy
shows you how simple [__] be man it's
like you dangle that carrot in front of
him gave him the PPP loans and you know
they they want them back for real
it is crazy because a lot of
um my homies
who you know like I I think he's gonna
do well with with black males in in the
next election
because a lot of my boys are like man
we're [__] with Trump and I'm like
really like
yeah I mean I think overall he won't you
know what I'm saying like no overall but
I think compared to like whatever he did
last time yeah he might get like that
two percent you know I mean but in Mass
he's not gonna get the black vote I mean
like black people are not stupid some of
the guys are very greedy but
um in Mass he won't get the black folk
but he's not relying on that he's not
leaning on that his base is just as
fired up as they ever been I wonder at
this point how it escalates because
the last escalation was was January 6th
them trying to destroy they own Capital
just like which is crazy I'm like I
don't claim this yeah how are you
supposed to be patriotic this is the
thing you love you're the one that runs
around with the American flag on your
pickup truck and you know your jacket
and this is what I tell everybody I'm
like yo anytime like if if
you know I like like I had to kind of
come to a realization
in the middle of his presidency because
I was to the point where like if I found
out you were like a Trumper I just
couldn't talk to you and I had like
family got that way I had family members
they got their way it got that way right
you got that way I'd still be trying to
get past that so I had to kind of come
to the realization that like okay not
everybody who voted for this guy is a
bad person right right
um but then I'm like okay but if you're
out here with a [__] Maga flag on
your truck it's pretty brazy that's
that's just a crazy like that's some
cult [__] it'd be like if someone like I
judge the same type of human being if
there was a giant Joe Biden flag on your
truck I'd be like yo are we going to be
that fanatical about any particular
politician not everybody who drinks the
Kool-Aid is the devil but I've had to
come to a place where
I can recognize that just because
someone is conservative or might be
racist or prejudiced that it doesn't
serve me
to judge them and be upset with them for
like I was in this uh Russian like Spa
the other day in Chicago got this
amazing it's got the hottest sauna the
coldest cold plunge and yo it's hard to
find a spot in LA with the cold plunge
and the [__] jacuzzi the cold plunge
is so crazy but uh you know the dude he
he's got to race his vibe to him you
know I can pick up on it right and uh
then I went in most recently and I saw
he had the um
he had conservative news channel just
playing in the common area right and I'm
like okay I properly interpreted right
you know this guy's energy but at the
same time it's like man that's between
him and God man I was leaving the mosque
one time and I've seen two brothers on
the corner talking there was a bunch of
Nigerian guys who were loudly debating
something as Nigerians do and one of
them was like man them Nigerian Brothers
they be deep man and the other one was
like man but they be racist and then the
first one was like that's between them
and Allah and I thought that was so deep
because there are a lot of
misunderstandings between us as black
people and Africans that I see both
sides of it because I'm gone in right
and I'm black American
um there's a lot of racism that goes
both ways uh I don't think a lot of
people are
hip to that that that's a thing that
exists yeah yeah that's that's that's
that's a reality but
that exists for us wherever we go
there's psychological propaganda that's
used to devalue Black Americans is used
to devalue Black Africans that's used to
pit them against each other because the
moment in time when we realize that we
have a unified front we have a common
enemy it would be too dangerous and too
powerful I mean that's why Martin Luther
King was killed that's why you know
Malcolm X once he started to move away
from a black separatism mind State and
embrace people of other cultures things
get really dangerous same thing for
Martin Luther King once he moved his
Focus From the March on Washington to uh
Poor People's movement
then he gets smoked because when you put
those dots together you connect those
dots then you get a red dot on your head
that's how it goes
but for me I had to realize like okay
this dude might be racist yes he might
be looking at me with a certain
Prejudice I can interpret it
that's between him and God like as long
as he doesn't try me what does it have
to project that on to you you know he's
projecting it but as long as it's not
impeding my ability to do what I have to
do what does that have to do what does
it have to do with me so I feel the same
way about trumpism at this point it's a
lot of people that may be drinking that
Kool-Aid and caught up in either the
hateful ideology or rhetoric and racism
and anti-Semitism and a mixture of the
two but
that's between them and God I'm not
walking around mad like right I see you
you [__] with Trump and now I'm like
[__] you yeah I mean I'm not doing that
just it's not worth it what do you think
is like the answer because like you said
it's always a lesser two evils
conversation and to me it's like
what it to me like trying to figure out
how to break up the two parties is you
know because I look at like like when
Bernie was running in 20 was it 2020
yeah and he uh he won the first two or
three primaries
and then once Biden won South Carolina
all the other DNC people just dropped
out and it was like all the energy was
behind by it and changed the election
but like for me it's like
no matter what whether you're Democrat
you're Republican both parties are
extremely corrupt both parties are in
bed with special interest groups a lot
of the same special interest groups you
know what I'm saying like and and that's
why I was like man if I vote third party
a lot of people say I'm throwing my vote
away but I'm like at least it's like the
beginning of like trying to like
maybe it's three percent this time maybe
in four more years it's 12 vote third
party like to me like
trying to figure out a way to get out of
that two-party system is like got to be
the answer eventually I don't know if
the answer can be found in capitalism
you can't dismantle the Master's house
using the Master's tools and the power
structure of this nation was built on
the literal backs of people that look
like me right and
I can't see how our Liberation our
freedom is going to be Reliant or
dependent upon them finding a conscience
you know I mean I think the answer has
to be in collectivizing our power the
answer's got to be in the artist putting
their heads together and putting aside
their differences unifying to
restructure what the economics of our
communities look like and the athletes
refusing to play ball until they get
ownership collectivizing their power and
reinvesting that into their communities
our communities aren't going to get the
Boost that they need and stop being
exploited or oppressed because the
Democrats decide so right because the
Democrats
split into and it starts at the ground
level for sure it's got to be among the
people man it's like that's that's how
power rises from the people it's not
going to be top down that doesn't make
sense to me because they all eat off us
that's why I don't consider myself a
Democrat or you know anything like that
because I know that the Democrats are
just as responsible for putting my [__]
change in jail as the Republicans they
wrote the law too yeah they actually are
the ones that put the law into effect
and they're in the White House now
that [__] is still reverberating through
our community so I don't consider myself
as a part of them but that doesn't mean
that I don't take value from the things
that they do well and the integration of
socialist policies into it and I think
Bernie was a great and has been a great
I love Bernie you know ideator in a
political space to really push some
Necessary Things forward a dude like
Bernie he's so ill because his receipts
is there
and he's still going and like pulling up
a Killer Mike to Amazon warehouses and
like you know what I'm saying that's the
type of dude I stand behind it's not a
party or a 100 percent
that's how I felt because I was like yo
who's like the consistent like who's
just a good guy like to me I thought
Bernie was like obviously a good person
who's never like kind of straight away
from his mission you know what I mean so
shout out to Bernie man for you uh as
somebody who is an activist as somebody
who's done so much for your community
would you ever consider getting into the
political space locally no
not a chance man never
um no definitely not I'm I'm political
20 years from now I'm politically minded
but I would not want to be a politician
that's not where my heart is at you know
I mean I think politicians by Nature
have to lie too much and I think we all
know that
you know I don't be holding my tongue
like that hey but that might work in
your favor but there's so much lying and
compromising with people's lives that
comes along with politics and
you just have to accept that like you
can be the most values driven
progressively minded politician but in
order to be effective and get things
done you got to cut the deal with the
fop and that's not me I'm not cutting
the deal with the Fraternal Order of
Police I'm not doing it you know I don't
want to be in that position because
that's just not that's not me you know
so people ask me would I ever step into
politics and I never would never would
consider it no I wouldn't even think
about it I think you could have been
mayor Chicago man I don't want to be
married what was the last mayor was it
Lori Lightfoot was that shout out to
Brandon Johnson no that's my boy is he
the new mayor he's the new mayor and the
previous mayor she was a hilarious
person to watch online her suits were
really uh she was like a meme you know
there was that there was did you ever
see the the there was like the
interaction between her and some like
some guy on Yelp I didn't see that it
was so funny she just wasn't
she didn't have a constituency and she
wasn't open to addressing what was
really going on like when she had a
conversation set up with me
she um found out you know that I was
very critical of the police that's her
name right Lori life for her life yeah
she found out I was so critical to the
police and so she just canceled the
conversation because she wasn't willing
to like actually
discuss what's going on in the city you
know I mean Chicago is a city with
so many harsh realities that it's like
how could we ever move forward if we
don't face those realities I think we
have a lot of subcultures and ideas in
our culture that are destroying us too
like op culture the idea of Ops is one
way that we've been brainwashed in
Chicago and in every hood and in rap
music
to believe that we are innately against
or enemies of ourselves it's almost like
we're staring in the mirror pointing a
gun at ourself because we've been taught
that you're from this block I'm from
this block you inherit that we are Ops
we are enemies and so we romanticize it
but I think in many ways we've been
misled and it's just a manifestation of
our own self-hatred we've been taught to
hate ourselves and so we turn it into oh
you my op even though you look just like
me and you're from the same
circumstances as me right but you're
from a different block two streets away
we don't own these projects right we
don't own these Section Eight houses we
don't own these vacant Lots we don't own
these liquor stores we don't own these
gas stations but we die for them every
day it doesn't make sense there's so
much Mis-Education and misinformation so
I'm saying we need to dispel and
dissipate the whole op culture the whole
idea it's exhausting man and and I'm
like you know me I'm a huge hip-hop head
but like I am so disconnected from so
much of the politics in that world I
know there's other platforms that are
notable that like dive more into that
[__] and I'm just like like when a guy
from Chicago comes on my show like I
don't usually I don't know what the [__]
I'm not even interested in talking about
any of that stuff yeah but that's good
bro that's good because a lot of people
like man a lot of guys I see the
interviews and you know they they like
just try to stand on that
um and
try to force these artists to speak
about their Ops or who they've bickered
with and who they have beef with and
then if they don't want to you know like
either take offense or you know it's
like
I think that the role of a journalist or
uh a steward of culture as as you are
and people that are your contemporaries
is one that has to be treated with a lot
of respect and a lot of reverence man
because
there's so much influence and it's like
this music that we make that we aspire
to rise from out of the gutter with and
we put our heart and our soul into it
and oftentimes it's a reflection of good
and bad everything that's around us
um
man it can bring a lot a lot of murder
behind it and it's the people that sit
in that seat that can either
help us to transcend and express what
you know what is important to us and
what's valuable to us or try to chain us
to where we came from and it's like man
I know it's clickbait I know it helps
yeah I mean it's yeah to me it's like yo
There's real like lives
to me it's like I gotta be able to why
you want me to talk about and why you
want me to talk about it on record
that's the thing I think is crazy about
hip-hop is like
I think that we've reached an era and an
age when
snitching on yourself and
self-incrimination
people uh encouraging you to incriminate
yourself is that an all-time high you
get on here and they want you to
give a detailed account of what crimes
you've committed I'll have to stop
artists and interviews sometimes and
I'll have to hit them with the allegedly
allegedly yeah allegedly because like I
might get allegedly whatever it's such a
catch-22 though because
we've seen that those things go viral so
if you're a young artist or a young
[__] in the street aspiring to be an
artist and you see somebody catch a
murder and that Skyrocket their career
yeah that can heat your career up if you
can talk about it or you that can really
excite somebody to think okay well maybe
this is a way that I can change my life
my family's life because it's working
for everybody else being on Front Street
about some Street [__] or going to do
some Street [__] making the music about
it for sure and the record labels profit
from us
you're incentivized to do that because
it's good for your career in theory for
your life it's not good for the bigger
picture but you know what was super wild
to me man was like realizing that
everywhere is not like this like not
even in hip-hop you know being in South
Africa which is also a pretty violent
explosive Place yeah in its ways
um
but learning that their hip-hop scene is
like
that doesn't fuel your career that
doesn't help you then your scene is
harder to Market and I was like it's
crazy because it's the opposite in
America it's like if you're stamped and
your criminal history is solidified then
this can be the main it can it can give
you a career but I do legitimately but I
do think it also puts a ceiling on you
because there are certain like like [__]
rolling loud like now you know they'll
they'll not book an artist because the
hip-hop police in New York is on their
ass you know some of these drill guys in
New York that have issues and my whole
approach to the whole situation is like
I've had very few situations where I've
had any sort of conversations that were
like beef driven and if it ever gets
brought up it'd be because
like there was two there's two guys from
Jacksonville that have like
Jacksonville's crazy and I I in our
interview because I know both of them I
know both the guys Julio and young and
Ace and the only time we touched on the
subject was like how do you guys like
squash this because you guys are from
the same city like is there a way to
ever put this behind you guys and set an
example you know what I mean like that
that that you guys could be bigger than
whatever has already happened because I
think that's really the hardest thing is
like one convincing artists that like
yes
when you're on YouTube and the algorithm
is feeding you these weird ass Hood
documentaries that these faceless
YouTubers make so strange that [__] is
so there's a whole Mega micro economy on
YouTube of faceless YouTube creators
that just do Hood comments industry beef
it's crazy Drew you don't know what
these guys look like maybe somewhere in
Utah
it's real [__] it's like hip-hop is in
that way like trauma porn for people
outside of our community yeah you know
we don't need to sit and watch that
because that's going on in our real life
but like you said if you're an artist
and like you're trying to get a buzz
it's like almost like well how do I make
people give a [__] and well I know that
this is what people will care about but
then there's real life consequences to
that you might lose your life your
friend might lose your life
you know to me it's like yo how do we
try to get past because like you said
the op culture to me it's like a cloud
over hip hop the last like five years
that's just like oh it's just too much
sometimes man like I'm exhausted by it
bro like I just feel like we as black
men have to normalize conflict
resolution we have to normalize
peacemaking we have to normalize letting
things go letting things go is the
importance we have to recognize that
oftentimes the real strength the real
power is in letting something go that's
much more difficult I had to learn that
it takes a lot more out of me to
Let It Go than it does for me to take it
to a violent space because that's the
way and you're carrying conflict with
you at all times subconsciously you
don't even realize it I had a situation
man in Chicago where you know something
from my past came back and someone that
had robbed me and was very close to me
and
um you know ultimately pop back up with
like a real disrespectful aggressive uh
attitude and approach and
in that moment
I decided to give it absolutely no power
to respond not at all so when he was as
close to me as you are now telling me
what he gonna do see me here there I
just said
may God bless you bro got up and left
yeah you know started to hit my phone
I said God bless you blocked it move on
hit me from different numbers but what I
learned was
in exercising that restraint which was
so difficult for me and putting it to a
space of God and prayer and just letting
it go
the situation fell a part of its own
weight so much more easily than if I had
engaged it in a violent way and but
we're not we're not taught that that
conflict resolution and non-violent
conflict resolution is ultimately
more beneficial because a lot of times
in the past I would handle something
differently and I would go handily in a
violent way and now look next thing you
know bootleg KFC is me on TV with a gun
case because I'm in the spiral of
Revenge paranoia I'm keeping this on me
all the time because
somebody might come and retaliate for
something that I've done right I can't
create the right way because you're
always parent because I tell people when
you got beef with like you know what my
Studios at it's a subconscious [__]
because you're always on like kind of
your guard's always up well that's the
thing that we experience man it's like
we live in a constant state of survival
mode and the Brain
reacts to that like we're in the wild at
fear of lions attacking us our amygdala
is responsible for the cortisol that
keeps us in fight-or-flight moment and
in our communities in our neighborhoods
were always in fight-or-flight mode
because you're always ready to either
kill or be killed so especially while
you beefing with people and experiencing
the opposite it's like you're amygdala
and your cortisol is overactive so
you're constantly tense you're
constantly stressed you're ready to go
at any time and
for me it's hard to like
from a place of peace and like really be
focused on what's important when I'm
doing that and it just ultimately it
[__] the money up it [__] the spirit
up [__] the energy energy for sure you
know find yourself in a jail cell or you
know worse